[Music]
foreign
[Music]
brings the star power at her Savage X
Fenty volume 4 show so what kind of
talent are you bringing into the mix
this time around
[Music]
and Riri she wasn't kidding the fashion
designer pulled out all the stops with
an All-Star lineup like drum roll please
Johnny Depp
[Music]
yep that's the actor walking through a
hazy Forest rocking a set from Rihanna's
line we like to challenge ourselves and
challenge tradition and find new ways of
redefining sexy and yeah it's fun you
know the Savage show is not really just
a fashion show it's an experience and
there's so many
uh aspects of entertainment all collided
into this one experience part of that
entertainment a performance from Maxwell
[Music]
we have Maxwell oh honey do you need to
say more is literally one of my favorite
performers but absolutely excited to see
him perform this year and Anita put it
all on display
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
but those weren't the only celeb cameos
ready for it Angela Aguilar avani Greg
Bella porch cara de Levine damson Idris
arena shake Joan Smalls cornbread Lara
Stone Lily Singh Marseille Martin
preciously Ricky Thompson
cimuliou Taraji P Henson Taylor Page
Winston Duke Zach Miko and Cheryl Lee
Ralph were all there too oh I love me
yeah I loved it I didn't know if I was
gonna love green as much as I was like
oh it's very nice and it felt so good
but perhaps the biggest star of all Riri
herself who shredded her stuff to the
song DMB by her man ASAP Rocky
[Music]
bad girls Wanna Have Fun bad girls Wanna
Have Fun bad girls Wanna Have Fun The
Collection is all about self-expression
and personal empowerment I always want
to bring new light to
maybe things that we've overlooked
before back in May Rihanna gave birth to
her and Rocky's first child a son whose
name has yet to be revealed what is the
best part about motherhood right now
Rihanna oh my God the morning's just
like seeing his morning face and you
know like seeing a baby with like little
bags and waking up and they're just like
startled they're trying to figure out
where they at is the cutest it's my
favorite part of the day
thank you